trois ans après le meurtre du petit
grégory
on découvre des éléments nouveaux qui
pourraient orienter l'enquêté
différemment pour l'instant le magistrat
chargé de la reconstitution exclu
l'hypothèse selon laquelle christine
villemin si elle est coupable serait la
seule coupable en tout cas christine
villemin a reçu un renfort si on peut
l'appeler ainsi important avec le
constat du médecin légiste celui ci en
effet à préciser que l'immersion dans la
rivière du petit garçon se situer à
partir de 20h30 or christine villemin
possède un alibi dès 17h30 roland sicard
trois ans presque jour pour jour après
les faits l'enquêté du juge maurice
simon semble avoir avancé d'un pas hier
les experts ont été formels le port du
petit grégory n'a pu être jeté dans la
vologne qu'ici même dans le centre du
village de dos erres dans cette
hypothèse difficile de croire que le
crime ait été commis en plein jour sous
le regard d'éventuels témoins grégory
aurait été plus vraisemblablement
assassiné à la tombée de la nuit une
heure à laquelle christine villemin
était déjà avec sa famille à la
recherche de son fils un point important
pour la défense pourtant des charges
continuent à peser sur christine
villemin les jeunes femmes qui ont
affirmé l'avoir vu à la preste de
lépanges à l'heure précise où le port
beau envoyer la lettre revendu pour le
meurtre ont maintenu leurs déclarations
si elles ne se trompe pas l'hypothèse
d'une complicité de christine villemin
serait toujours envisageable cet après
midi le juge simon va continuer son
enquête il est décidé à tout faire pour
tenter d'éclaircir enfin le mystère de
la mort du petit grégory